hello everyone and welcome back to some
top level chess again we are back at the
tournament of Peace It's the final round
and Hans is having an incredible
tournament but so is Anon korobov and
this will make for a very interesting
final round between the two of them
korobov being the top seed of the
tournament and second highest rated
Ukrainian player uh currently second
only to pav Lov it's a it's a crazy game
you guys will enjoy it uh let's dive
straight into it so Hans has the white
pieces and he opened with Pawn to E4
Coro replies with C5 he goes for the
Sicilian Defense Knight to F3 we have D6
and Hans does not go for the open cilian
he goes for Bishop to C4 the canal
attack Knight to D7 and now we have
castles we have Pawn to A6 chasing the
bishop back and Bishop to D3 looks odd
but this is the top move that everyone
plays Knight G2 F6 and now Rook to E1 we
have Pawn to E6 by Anon uh and now uh
well top move here is Pawn to C3 usually
you make room for your Bishop on C2 and
then then you can advance the pawn to D3
or D4 depending on what the position
calls for but Hans goes back Bishop to
F1 and this is sort of hans's signature
move he already played it on quite a few
occasion uh we have Pawn to B6 and now
we have Pawn to C4 uh grabbing more
space here controlling D5 Hans played it
against he defeated Mustafa ilas he
defeated Alexander renko and he lost to
Anish giri with the same setup we have
Bishop to B7 Knight to C3 and now shifts
the Knight over to E5 getting ready to
capture on F3 sort of fighting against
the D4 because if D4 the Knight captures
on F3 and if you capture with the queen
then the D4 Pawn will hang but
interestingly that's exactly what Hans
does D4 Knight captures on F3 check and
now not Queen captures to allow C
captures on D4 H plays G captures on F3
and he voluntarily messes up his Pawn
structure in front of the king but he
does have a massive Center here and
Anisha in his game that he won played c
cap s D4 he was played last year in the
FDX crypto cup but here we have Pawn to
G6 by Anon and now we have Bishop to E3
uh there is again Bishop to G5 um Peter
mishik played it against Vincent kimer
and U last year and kimer was able to
win that game but here we have Bishop to
E3 and it is now as of move 12 that we
have a completely new game so okay uh
pretty solid setup by Anon nothing to
worry about here he fetos the bishop and
now Queen to D2 We have castles and now
how does Hans continue the game he goes
Rook a to D1 of course the Rooks belong
on uh soon to be open lines and now
Bishop to C6 again sort of a weird move
but once you know why it's there makes
perfect sense it adds support to B5 and
you can play Rook to B8 or queen to B8
to add more support the pawn to B5 but
Hans now goes Bishop to G5 sort of a
wasting a Tempo not going for the move
that um mishal played against Vincent
kimer but plays Bishop to E3 followed by
Bishop to G5 first and now Anon says
right I will just unpin I wanted to play
Queen to B8 either way uh and pawn to D5
okay we have Capt capts attacking the
bishop Bishop to D7 and now Hans goes
Knight to E2 Shifting the Knight over to
G3 uh Rook to E8 and now Bishop to G2 we
have Pawn to B5 Anon very happy with his
setup continuing his play on The Queen
side H and now Hans plays something that
uh well just looks very very odd uh but
once you see it you realize how scary it
is he plays King to H1 and it's one of
those moves that can either be a nice
prophylactic idea to you know sort of
get get off of this diagonal so you
don't get some sort of a check in the
future and you blunder a rook H but here
hunts actually does it to put Rooks on
the G file which looks crazy I mean
there's so much stuff here on the G file
how will that how will that help you
well hun is here to demonstrate we have
Pawn A5 corov not impressed he continues
um he's play on The Queen side Knight to
G3 by Hans we have Pawn to H5 and now h
plays Rook to G1 and now already you can
feel that if you move the Knight some
Knight captures on H5 action might
happen or even Bishop captures on F6
Bishop captures and then Knight captures
on H5 will expose the black king for
example if the bishop were to move from
G2 so there are some things to consider
here Anon plays Rook to A7 will add more
support to the seventh Rank and now Hans
plays Bishop to F1 uh he could go for
Knight to F5 right away also could be
very scary but he has a different idea
Bishop to F1 Pawn to C4 Anon again
continues playing on the queen side he
says all right you shuffle your pieces
here I'm just going to do my thing
Bishop to E2 and now Bishop to C8 Now
The Rook gains access to the uh to the
seventh Rank and here Hans plays Bishop
captures on F6 it's sort of a different
way of um accomplishing the same thing
the other one would be the immediate
Knight to F5 point being that you cannot
capture here if you capture then Bishop
captures on F6 and you you can just
resign here uh but if Bishop captures
and E captures now it uh gets a lot of
fun because even though white has
tripled pawns here let's say Knight H7
goes after the bishop you move the
bishop and now Knight to f8 adding
support to G6 uh F4 is coming and now
look at this let's say Rook to C7 you
prepare for further pushing on the on
the queen side as that's what corov has
been doing the entire game you're even
going to play Bishop captures on H6 and
now you can't go for this because of F6
and you're going to lose the bishop on
G7 so let's say queen to C8 now f
captures and G6 F captures and Bishop G4
attacks the queen queen moves and now
Pawn to F5 you get rid of all of your
tripled and doubled pawns you open up a
path towards the black king and uh well
uh win the game so that is possible but
Hans goes for for a similar idea Bishop
captures Bishop captures and just Knight
captures and H5 now that the G Pawn is
pinned uh Bishop back to h8 and now
Queen to H6 there's a there's a huge
threat in the position and to give you
an example let's say black continues
pushing and says all right you got
nothing here the threat is Rook captures
on G6 F captures and now not this uh to
allow uh the king to move but first Rook
to G1 that's how you win it and now
there's really not much you can do if
Rook to G7 even Knights to F6 with check
uh forces the king away from the defense
of the bishop and if King F7 first
you're going to eliminate the rug then
the bishop and uh black collapses so
after Rook to H6 Queen to B6 was played
and this is an ingenious way of
Defending by Anon Kobo he's is not um
that strong for a reason also uh the top
seed of the tournament his idea is here
that if Hans was were to uh proceed with
Rook captures and G6 his idea is that
now after F captures and Rook to G1 he
has this queen to D4 move and now after
Queen captures on G6 King f8 there's no
good way for white to continue this it's
actually um nothing more but a glorified
draw after King E7 Knight to G7 now uh
Shifting the Knight over to E6 because
if you capture then Rook captures on G7
followed by some Rook captures on E7
action and also if Rook to f8 then you
get Knight to E6 and it's pretty bad
black has nothing better than to take a
draw here King to d8 Queen captures on
D6 you have to defend the Rook King to
E8 and now Queen to E6 check King d8 and
here they will agree to a draw but H
says no thank you he just plays Rook to
G2 also adds a Defender to F2 might be
relevant and prepares a rook D to G1 to
bring even more Firepower to the G file
uh we have Rook e to E7 sorry Rook e to
E7 and now we have Pawn to F4 Hans
figures out that you can give up the D4
Pawn uh as Rook captures and G6 again
becomes an option uh since the the two
Rooks are very much needed here but also
if if captures and captures then
captures captures with check the queen
also connects nicely with that Rook on
e4 so Rook captures and E4 was played uh
but now Rook captures on G6 with check f
captures and now Queen captures on G6 so
what can you do here well King to f8 and
now not capturing The Rook but Hans
plays the only move that wins the game
and I'm sure you guys know which one it
is even without me telling you well the
move of course is Queen to H6 with check
and now how do you defend well uh if you
go Bishop to G7 uh sorry Bishop to G7
was played but if you go King to E7 the
the the idea was Rook to G1 and uh uh
you can just give so many pieces here
you can give up the bishop P E2 and then
Rook to G8 and you can even give up the
F2 Pawn sort of uh getting you know an
inch to being checkmated but now Queen
to f8 check King D7 and queen to d8 will
be Checkmate as the pawn covers these
two squares so that's the idea so after
Queen to H6 check Bishop to G7 was
played and now Knight captures on G7
Rook captures on G7 and just Rook to G1
uh threatening to pick up the Rook here
and uh again Queen to D4 looks like a
move but it's really not because if you
play Queen to D4 then comes Queen to h8
with check and after King to F7 as you
do have to defend your Rook here uh
there's this killer Bishop to H5 check
and then after King to E7 you play Queen
to E8 with check and after King F6 Queen
to f8 check and after Rook to F7 you
just take it and Checkmate the black
king but Anon as strong as he is he he
figures out a way on how to defend this
he plays Bishop to G4 which seems silly
you're just giving up um a bishop here
but it's it's it's really not the point
is that uh if the Rook captures the
bishop which seems like something you
might do you don't feel like it changes
anything but what um what did this move
accomplish do you realize why Anon
sacrificed the bishop here to prevent
the light Square Bishop from delivering
that important check that we discussed
and now Queen to D4 you can actually
defend you don't have this queen to H
check King F7 and Bishop to H5 check and
black will have just enough enough tempy
to hold the game however after Bishop to
G4 hun said nope Bishop captures on G4
and now it's very very difficult Queen
to D4 okay now the The Rook does not
control G7 but now Bishop to E6 takes
away the F7 Square Queen h8 is a threat
and Anon without moves here sadly even
if he gives up The Rook for the bishop
here still Queen to h8 check King to F7
and now D captures on E6 with check
again uh removing the king from the
defense of the Rook if you go here then
the queen no longer defends you have to
move and then Queen captures or Rook
captures will leave you up too much
material so after Bishop D6 said all
right Queen cap on B2 I'm either
surviving this or or I'm getting
checkmated uh but he is getting
checkmated Queen to h8 check was played
King to E7 with rook captur and G7 with
check King F6 and here Hans played Queen
to H6 and it was UND this move on move
39 that Anon korobov got checkmated so
incredible game incredibly powerful line
something that Hans plays quite often
like I said with with good results I
only found that he lost that game to an
jiri uh at the at the absolute highest
level but yeah now he defeats Anon Coro
top seat of the tournament and he uh
wins the tournament of pce in Zagreb
with an incredible result he won it with
eight out of nine and second place is a
sort of a shared second place between an
burkic Anon corov and vasil ivanchuk
with five out of nine so he wanted three
full points ahead of the field uh which
is uh which is astonishing and uh just
to give you uh sort of who he played
against here eight out of nine you can
see only draw against creation Grand
Masters herich and an burkic he he
crushed everyone else and uh only in
this month he won 34.7 points and he's
almost back to 2700 so he's currently at
93.7 uh and that is that is at this
level that is can only be considered a
meteoric rise and some some of the other
Juniors that are doing really well jav
karov also broke 2700 he's up 20 points
G lost a lot he lost 26.2 points much
like Ali Resa
26.1 but Ali Resa was so so much higher
rated than everyone else that even with
losing 26 points he's still down to only
2750 and then yeah okay Prague not not
much difference here Vincent also a big
winner plus 16.9 plus 14 for RI nrec
plus four and yeah Juniors doing doing
pretty well aside from this um bad month
gcash and alz are having uh but yeah
incredible performance Hans go you know
walking in the footsteps of the great
Bobby Fisher that marked the tournament
of Peace by winning it brilliantly in
1970 uh but hunts did it without a loss
here like I said for those of you who
haven't seen the Fisher game against
kovachevich the only game that fisher
lost in this tournament in 1970 uh first
link in the description below it's it's
a master class of the French defense if
you're a French player you have to know
that game uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it a bit of a uh a
bit of a you know a breeder from all of
my rapid games that I've been playing to
enjoy some top chess as well so hope you
enjoyed that I would like to thank David
gasparian Muhammad Solan David Anthony
Robert Kendal and Diane Schwarz for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and everything
else that happens in the Chess World uh
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day